obsession of us workshop I suggested
very suggest that first seven talks that
have introduced us to some fascinating
applications and we're going to continue
in that vein today with one of the most
fascinating and demanding computational
problems around our speakers
[Music]
okay well it's great to be here today to
talk to you a little bit about the Large
Hadron Collider as you can see here I've
started with some snapshots to show the
trajectory of what we're doing so what
you can see on the left or a couple of
candidate events which were some of the
signals that were used extracted from
the data to do the Higgs boson discovery
in the middle you see the detector that
I work on the CMS detector I know that I
just met a member of the Atlas
collaboration who's here in the audience
and I'll tell you about the Higgs
discovery what lies beyond and perhaps
in the second part mostly I'll get into
some of the data challenges and may
maybe we'll even have time to talk about
some of the applications of deep
learning methods which are really having
an impact on our field we'll see how it
goes first thing to say is these are
some of the young people in our research
team and these are the real heroes of
this story who are really the ones most
responsible for much of the work and for
the discoveries and applications and of
new methods so what high energy physics
is all about is to understand the most
fundamental constituents of matter and
the forces between them and also how our
universe has gotten to the present
namely what happened at the origins at
and right after the Big Bang how things
have evolved and whether or not the
present physics that we see is the
physics of the early universe as it was
in the first moments I think we can
already say the answer to that question
is no now we have a great description of
a lot of what's happening but we know
there are fundamental flaws and if we
try to to project back to the early
moments of the universe basically that
picture is not only incomplete but in
some ways doesn't work at all
like some other disciplines this is an
area which attracts some of the very
best young people who really love to
grapple with such fundamental questions
being at Caltech is also great because
it's a great theme of undergraduate
research so in our team over the years
we've had well over 100 under graduates
who've made in many cases significant
contributions to this so what we
understand so far is a beautiful simple
picture I tried to capture a lot of it
here many of you know that our
understanding of matter includes three
families of quarks strongly interacting
constituents and matter in which the
first generation the up and down quarks
shown in the upper left is what
constitutes normal matter working with
the accelerators people have discovered
other generations for us what's called
the charm and strange Court the strange
quark in the 50s and the charm quark the
third generation top and bottom quark
these families are complemented by a set
of families of what are called leptons
leptin for light there are charged
particles the most familiar is the
electron in the 40s a muon was
discovered in 1975 the third charge left
on the top particle was discovered at
the Stanford Linear Accelerator Center
not far from here and each of these
leptons is accompanied by a different
type of neutrino
very weakly interacting particles that
escaped our detectives without being
detected and now there are specialized
experiments that actually can there are
so many neutrinos in those that you can
detect neutrino interactions and this is
complemented by four force carriers for
the fundamental interactions we have the
electromagnetic interaction the weak
interaction those two are unified in a
very predictive a unified theory called
the electroweak theory and there's also
the strong interaction for example
that's the interaction responsible for
finding nuclei together in which the
quarks
Cepeda the weak interaction is carried
by too heavy particles a Z zero which
has no electric charge and the W which
is charged in this picture until
recently until a few years ago the
missing element was the higgs boson
which is thought to give matter to
elementary particles and now in a
restricted sense that theory is
completed however the standard model has
a number of shortcomings it doesn't
include a quantum description of gravity
it doesn't have a candidate for what
makes up the dark matter in the universe
if you projected back to the early
moments I already said that only the
forces of nature not unified they come
to a single original force but the
theory doesn't work anymore at least the
way we understand it we don't understand
why there's so much more matter than
antimatter in the universe not really we
don't know where the pattern of particle
masses comes from and we have no idea
what to say about dark energy being a
particle physicist you expect that it's
made up of particles but we actually
cannot prove that so we have this
beautiful simple picture and so many
questions are unanswered and related to
that maybe you've heard talks about
astrophysics and cosmology although we
understand much about matter 95% of the
matter in our universe and energy is
unknown to us so being from Caltech this
picture of relativistic quantum field
theories which describe these
interactions started with with Fineman
whoo there you see him lecturing at
Caltech in 1960 and he's the one who
came up with quantum electrodynamics
after taking 12 years to prove that his
thesis adviser was completely wrong
which i think is a great lesson for us
to me
then after that is the whole arc of
unifying elect romantic and weak
interactions the three gentlemen LaShawn
Weinberg Weinberg Salaam and glasha are
shown there and that also introduced the
concept which I'll say more of of what's
called electroweak symmetry breaking the
third interaction the strong interaction
actually fits into the same framework
but how to do that theoretically was a
mystery until in the 2000s some young
physicists including one who's in my
building
David Pulitzer came up with the idea of
asymptotic freedom namely the quarks
although they interact strongly when
they're produced in an interaction or at
small distances the strength of the
interaction goes down so you can use the
same what's called perturbative
framework to calculate things to two
subsequent orders and come up with
reliable predictions and it's the Higgs
boson that's supposed to be the source
of electro weak symmetry breaking this
is just a picture of it because when we
go through some of the signatures this
is a great way to introduce it
so when quarks or gluons which bind
particles strongly interacting particles
when quarks emerge from the interaction
point to the greater and greater
distances instead of the force between
between them getting weaker it gets
stronger and eventually it becomes so
strong and the energy density is so high
that additional particles are produced
from the vacuum and instead like in the
picture on the right from a previous
experiment that was on you see these
Jets of particles come out so we don't
see quarks and gluons in nature but
instead we see their fragments the Jets
which appear in our detectives and so I
put together here's some vignettes
there's a nobel prize for my colleague
in the middle is of my reporting of the
discovery of gluons experimentally at a
conference at Fermilab
which I reported in 1979 and some of the
first color graphics displays which show
these deaths from my first graduate
student okay so about the Higgs
discovery until July 4th 2012 this was
the only Higgs known Peter who's
visiting our experiment but experiments
until that time had already made
searches and they could exclude more and
more of the possible mass ranges and so
by the time the discovery claimed there
was only this narrow region left in
which it could be and then on July 4th
of course it was discovered so I was
discovered on July 4th 2012 by March
2013 people were convinced this is the
Higgs boson predicted by the standard
model of particle physics and it was a
wonderful time in our field because it
wasn't only a discovery in physics it
seemed to have been taken as an
achievement of humanity a worldwide
phenomenon and for example as the these
things were going on about a billion
people watch this in terms of science
the theory was first postulated not only
by Higgs but others on glare and brought
about the same time in 1964 then the
experiments to go after this among and
to look at the high-energy frontier for
things beyond the standard model those
concepts were put forward in 1984 I
studied the detector designs were
developed construction began in 2001 who
started taking data in 2009 and we had a
discovery in 2012 one thing I wanted to
emphasize because I also work a lot on
data networks his advanced computational
methods and networks are essential for
the discovery but for every also every
PhD thesis of the last 20 years in this
program and for all of the discoveries
to come
now before I get it into the Higgs
discovery a bit I want to emphasize the
mission of the LHC is not that that was
the first mission but the real mission
is to use it as a discovery machine so
the LHC collides protons at the highest
possible energy head-on with a bunch of
protons in the machine as you'll see
cross at a number of points and by doing
that what we really are doing is
colliding the constituents of the
protons the quarks and the gluons which
are inside the protons and what matters
in in terms of producing something new
is the center of mass energy that you
have available to produce new things so
on this large plot you look at what's
called a part on part on center of
energy where Parton could be a clerk
worker and gluon if you look at the
previous highest energy accelerator the
Tevatron at Fermilab would stop
operating just a couple of years ago it
cuts off at about 1,000 GV or one TV
equivalent energy in the center-of-mass
frame and the LHC goes out to several TV
now when we started this program we had
these very strong biases and we still
have the residual part of that bias
which is that we knew what was beyond
the standard model namely a very
appealing theory called supersymmetry
which unifies the symmetries of particle
physics you know space-time has a Dark
Matter candidate would work in the early
universe is stable at high energies and
all these things but until now unlike
our expectations is not there so we
really are searching in the unknown
maybe it's still possible that
supersymmetry exists shorthand Susy are
there sub structures of quarks and
gluons
there are other high-energy particles
resonances of other interactions for
example does gravity become strong at at
an energy scale we can access or their
microscopic black holes we don't think
so fortunately and other exotic things
we don't know what we're going to find
the good news is that since our early
expectations have not been realized when
we do learn something in this class of
wonderful possible things it will
revolutionize our thinking oh the
shortest possible summary is this nature
is more subtle another way to put it is
Einstein used to say I like to look in
the face of God the answer is
unfortunately she's a lot smarter than
you are so how does the Higgs boson work
so we say it brings mass to elementary
particles so there was a competition to
explain it to the public and this is one
of the winning explanations so imagine
you have the vacuum and it's represented
in the vacuum there all these
fluctuations so you can imagine if you
take a snapshot you'll see all these
particles living for an instant and
imagine you can represent them by all
these people a roomful of physicists at
a cocktail party and they're kind of
moving around and in this picture
talking to each other like all of space
figs filled with the Higgs field and
diner for well-known scientists there's
Albert Einstein walks in they all
cluster around him saw the Higgs field
clusters around a particle and he
becomes very massive and it can hardly
move and so this resistance to movement
is somehow analogous to how a particles
acquire mass there are similar things in
condensed matter physics you can even
find things that an electron moving in a
solid in the fiber lectures sometimes it
behaves like it has many electron volts
of equivalent energy and not not just
half and a half of an MeV okay so there
is this concept of spontaneous symmetry
breaking this is something which is
familiar in nature what it says is that
if I have a fundamental theory the
ground state doesn't have to necessarily
respect the symmetries which appear to
be evident in the theory so for example
if I have I I turn on a magnet or a
piece of iron becomes magnetized it
picks a particular direction
even though the interaction doesn't have
a particular direction but all the
domains tend to line up in some
direction or if I put water on a glass
pane and cool it down until it freezes
although it's a smooth surface suddenly
all these wonderful patterns of ice
crystals with symmetries appear so what
happens here is that the lowest state of
the vacuum is not at zero field if you
represent it here it's a so-called it's
called there's some rare old potential
namely there is a field it has a real
and imaginary part and if you say
where's the minimum of this field this
minimum of this potential it's at some
finite value of the field corresponding
to a certain nonzero mass and the
spontaneous symmetry breaking part is
where in the azimuthal direction on this
sombrero the you end up so it
spontaneously picks a certain direction
there's already a hint of a problem here
now that we've discovered the Higgs
boson to be at 125 GeV if you try to
carefully use your theory to project
backward in time which is equivalent to
projecting the very high energies you
find that the self coupling of this
field suddenly goes negative what does
that mean it means that we wouldn't be
living in a real vacuum that we would
transition to something else and we
wouldn't be here but we did get here
didn't we from the Big Bang until now
and so there's a question of what's
going on here if the Higgs boson is that
light maybe something else happens
there's an intermediate mass scale
between the energy of the Big Bang right
after the Big Bang let's say 10 to the
16 GB and where we are now and maybe
something else is happening okay
experimentally so maybe you've heard
talks about the Large Hadron Collider
before for those of you who haven't this
is a picture taken from a helicopter
down on the topography of Switzerland
and France
the accelerator the LHC which
accelerates and then collides bunches of
protons is actually below the ground in
Switzerland in France at a depth of
between 50 and 150 meters you can see
it's very large it has a circumference
of 27 kilometers and if you look on your
right you see the Geneva Airport very
important so you can also make out the
fact that this is an accelerator complex
if you look carefully you'll see that
the Atlas experiment is on the Swiss
side CMS is about 25 minutes the way
drive in France and there are two other
experiments if you look carefully in
your outlets you'll see there are
smaller circles there's a whole chain of
accelerators starting from a hydrogen
bottle that where the protons get
accelerated so there are four main LHC
experiments and there also a couple of
other specialized experiments I'll talk
mainly about the CMS experiment which I
understand in the greatest detail the
keys to discovery here are two things
one the highest possible energy so we
have a good probability of being able to
produce events containing Higgs bosons
and also intensity there's a certain
rate and you want to gain get a big
sample of events so that you can extract
the signals and then study them and
understand whether the standard model is
telling you all about the means by which
the particles are produced and how they
decay into the final state particles
that you measure this is how the LHC
works you can compare the design values
in terms of the number of bunches in the
machine how many protons are in a bunch
the beam energy and what's most
important to us is you can think of the
intensity it's called the luminosity for
a process which has a given predicted
rate we express it in what's called the
cross-section how many events do you get
there was a design luminosity which
people thought was just a real
I mean in some units is 10 to the 34 per
centimeter square per second for example
if you talk about strong the strong
interaction and how many interactions
you get when the particles collide 10 to
the 34 would be about 10 to the not 10
to the 9 interactions per second and in
fact amazingly to us we've gone beyond
that actually the experiments have been
running can only take so much in terms
of the complexity event events what's
called the pile up every time 2 bunches
cross you don't get one interaction you
get many even though they cross for a
fraction of a nanosecond every 25
nanoseconds within that that interval
you get many interactions and that
number has gone up to 50 or 60 at the
highest luminosities okay so as shown at
the top there's actually a common ring
of magnets with two places for the beams
bunches of protons counter-rotate and at
four points around the ring come
together and the bunches pass through
each other every once in a while a
proton in one bunch collides with a
proton and the other as I said but
you're really are colliding our quarks
and gluons and then you see these final
state particles the most common thing
you see are lots of particles Jets of
particles and then there are more rare
things and I'll say more about that
later but way down in this sequence
rather rare events you can produce Higgs
bosons and for the rare the case of the
Higgs boson sometimes we're looking at
one event in 10 to the 14 okay so to do
this program we need this large
accelerators such as the LHC detectors
which are also instruments of remarkable
complexity to record and differentiate
the types of particles coming up
interaction region looking at the
energies the topology and
characteristics of the events to
characterize what we know more precisely
and extra
new things new physics processes
computing grids the only way that you
can analyze all the data it's done
cooperatively at sites around the world
there are currently about 300 sites 13
national centers about a hundred and
sixty centers which are dimension that
can be run at the smaller labs and
universities and every physics group has
a cluster and they're about 300 of those
so the task there is to to collect a
store distributor analyze
collaboratively lots of data and of
course people physicists engineers
technologists all working together ok
how does the detector work as I said
there are particular points around the
ring where the bunches of protons cross
around those points that's where you
install your detection apparatus and
simply said there are multiple layers in
this detection apparatus which are
specialized to detect different types of
particles and will so go through that in
some detail we have to differentiate by
making measurements in the different
layers photons electrons muons quarks
which you see as Jets of particles and
addition neutrinos which are sometimes
produced as part of the interaction or
the decay of some of the particles they
escaped from the detector unseen and so
if you tried a balance in at least in
the transverse direction remember the
quarks and gluons can have some
longitudinal momentum because although
the protons have a total momentum of
zero a pair of protons the quarks and
gluons are meant to Sarila
but in the transverse plane transport to
the beamline
you should have a balance of momentum
and energy and if you don't see that the
the most probable thing in a standard
event is from the tree nose and then for
new physics signatures we look for
events with lots of missing in it
the transverse plane okay so here so
this is at the top of picture of the CMS
detector and has various layers an inner
tracker which is made up of first pixels
and then silicon strips which detects
charged particle tracks then there are
crystals an array of crystals seventy
six thousand crystals weighing about 90
tons which makes precise measurements of
electrons in photons and then outside
that is a superconducting coil which
provides a magnetic field a strong in
any field to bend charged particles and
allow them allow us to momentum analyze
them
oh yes and then also I didn't mention
there's also what's called a hadron
calorimeter after the electrons and
photons are absorbed in the crystals
then the most copious particles like
lions and kion's deposit some of the
energy in the crystals and some the next
layer called the hadron calorimeter and
again what's happening is we're
absorbing the energy and then in layers
interleave with a heavy material we're
able to sample the energy and get a
measure of the incoming energy of
individual particles outside the coil
there're then layers which are iron and
to return the high magnetic field flux
and multiple stations of what we call
muon chambers which gives us coordinates
in space so we can see the particles
called muons which don't interact
strongly unlike the electron they're a
bit heavier so they've managed to get to
the outside and seeing them inside and
outside like that tells you that it's a
muon so I have a little animation yeah
so you can see a muon that goes from the
inside to the outside and measured in
the multiple stations of the muon
chambers an electron you see the tracks
formed and then essentially it stopped
there's a cascade in the crystals and
all the energies absorbed they're in
neutral hadron no track in the inside
but then interacting strongly in the
Hadron Collider a charged Hadron like a
pion or a k on
the track inside and then depositing a
lot of its energy in the Hadron
calorimeter and a photon which of course
has no charge so it doesn't deposit
anything in the inner layers and it gets
absorbed in the crystals so those are
some of the basic patterns that we use
to distinguish particles and a lot more
analysis than that one thing to say
about electrons and photons is when
they're absorbed in the crystals the
pattern
among the many crystals each of which is
only two by two centimeters in
cross-section is characteristically
narrow the energies departed deposited
in only a few crystals and that tells
you helps you distinguish electrons and
photons from charge head runs as time
went on by about two thousand eleven to
twelve the time of the discovery instead
of just using the characteristics in the
different layers we started to use them
all together there was this global event
reconstruction in which we call particle
flow which was using all the information
in the in the different layers to come
up with what are called reconstructed
particles electrons muons photons
charged and neutral hadrons and then to
use them as building blocks from which
you could say that these are Jets of
particles that there's some missing
transverse energy maybe a sign of new
physics or just the usual effect of the
tree nose in the event we could build
heavy leptons how do have a
characteristic signature what I call the
tau leptons and try to pick out isolated
leptons because when a electron like an
electron or muon is isolated from many
of the other particles that's also part
of what could be a new particle
signature it helps us differentiate as
the intensity of the Machine increased
so did the amount of pileup and I'll
show you more about that and so one of
the motivations for this particle flow
code was to minimize the impact on the
basic objects when we reconstruct jet
energies when we identify in and measure
the energies of electrons or photons
and say how isolated they are we have to
remove the effect of an increasing
amount of pileup for every event of
interest we started in 2011 they were
accompanied by a few other interactions
maybe rather well separated in terms of
where along the bunching the bunch
crossing region where they occurred but
as the intensity went up that went to 20
and then to 40 and 50 and I must say the
original design said we would have to
deal with 17 and so now we're dealing
with 50 to 60 and eventually in the
second phase of the program called the
Large Hadron the Honda monastic Large
Hadron Collider starting around 2026 for
a decade
we have to deal with up to 200 so what
you could see this is at the time of
discovery we could show that as a
function the number of vertices that we
could maintain the muon isolation
identification at the bottom we could
maintain the high resolution for four
photons at the bottom this is a picture
in time-lapse picture of our detector
being built which took about six years
that's my colleague Maria who talked in
February and what's particular about our
experiment is it has these it's very
modular and so large pieces could be
preassembled pre commissioned on the
surface and lowered down and the pieces
going down a 2,000 ton crane would
lowered down would take about 11 hours
to go the 50 meters to the ground this
is a superconducting coil in the
heaviest piece which is 2,000 tons and
there's the arrival of the heaviest
piece this is the most ambitious magnet
ever built fortunately it works and so
it generates for Tesla field we operated
a little bit less because every once a
while not very often it quenches and
there's a it's life there's only so many
question ch's we've run it a bit below
for Tesla below about 40 kilojoules when
it's excited the
pressure Biggio pressure is 64
atmospheres if you calculate the energy
store in the magnetic field it's
comparable to the heaviest the kinetic
energy of an aircraft carrier moving at
about 20 miles an hour I one thing that
we've worked on among these many
detectors in our lab at Caltech is
crystals we've developed these heavy
scintillating crystals for various
experiments which are an important part
of the discovery so signatures involving
electrons and muons are among the most
distinctive features that there are we
also have built a laser monitoring
system while the crystals are sitting in
the radiation environment of the LHC
they undergo changes what happens is the
crystals which contain defects and/or
impurities what's formed under ionizing
radiation are called color centers and
the color centers change the
transparency of the crystals and so
every 40 minutes we check or measure the
transparency of each of the 76,000
crystals this is the laser okay now what
about the data readout well as you saw
CMS is a highly heterogeneous system if
you count the number of electronics
channels including the innermost pixel
detector which has a lot of those
channels the total is about 100 million
and you're sampling about every 25
nanoseconds the data flow from the
detector is of water 1 petabyte a second
and after pre filtering with hardware
and then filtering with many processors
in real time we end up there is about 50
exabytes a day in readout and online
processing throughout flowing through
this system I already mentioned this is
capturing what's happened with the
luminosity this is a record from not
quite all of last year in Atlas and CMS
this is showing about 80 percent of what
was collected and this is from 2016
going into 2017
so the amazing thing like I said is a
machine is really capable of twice the
design luminosity and we run a little
bit less than that the beams are
actually separated just a bit so we run
at about one and a half times designed
the Manasa T so that we get cleaner data
so this year is going to be a production
year there are some small problems well
for physicists weren't so small but in
the accelerator there were problems that
forced us to use less than the highest
number of events those problems are now
resolved we think and this is going to
be a production year for getting a lot
of data so this illustrates increasing
numbers of pileup starting in 2010 the
average number of piles of events was 2
in 2011 7 at the time of the discovery
up to about 20 in 2016 30 2017 40 to 50
and then you can see on the right some
of the scene many tracks coming out and
in on the right in the center and then
you can also see if you look in the
calorimeter layers how the energy is
deposited so as we get this enormous
data sample which gives us a great
opportunity for scientific discovery we
have to deal with more and more
complexity
so this is a plot that's just to
illustrate some of the things there are
more than ten to the nine interactions
per second on this plot this would be up
off at the top on these units about it's
about 10 to the 11 on this plot and you
can see that some of the interesting
events get down to 0.1 units in the
rarest decays from the total number of
interactions to the rarest interactions
there's about 14 orders of magnitude
okay so what a little bit about the data
taking first there is what's called the
trigger system in CMS the second level
is really done with without
general-purpose processors the first
level is Hardware where we take the
digital data and parts of the detector
actually slices the parts of the
detector the data which is then
digitized and digital data is looked for
patterns events are built from the
various parts and you do a pre selection
finally from the hardware trigger comes
out about a hundred kilohertz in the
next phase it'll be raised about 750
kilohertz as the limit and then you make
you make selections deciding which data
to keep so there are tens of thousands
of computing cores in our higher level
triggers and about a couple of hundred
trigger lines of what we're going to to
keep essentially filtering algorithms
and pieces of code and we typically
record about a gigabyte a second now and
then considering that we run for
something like four million seconds a
year that's a lot of data
okay so in dealing with his data I was
faced with this problem in 1999 and so I
came up with this cartoon which is how
the data would be handled namely by a
worldwide grid of facilities so data
flows in the experiment through the
trigger system record about a gigabyte a
second after filtering in multiple
stages first process that the laboratory
at CERN then sent to about 13 national
centers over networks which have
expanded in capability over over the
years now the current generation of
networks typical long long range wide
area links are about 100 gigabits a
second and then in this simple picture
which isn't really not the picture I'll
explain in a moment data from there
would be processed further out of what
are called the tier 2 centers and there
are now about 170 of those and then from
there the cluster is used by the
individual groups so the idea
functionally is that at the laboratory
site you at the experiment you do
real-time data processing at the
National Center is called Tier one you
do data and simulation now that's also
migrated to many of the tier two sites
and at the tier two and Tier three sites
is the main place where analysis is done
since this simple picture by the way
this simple cartoon went over very well
with the CERN managers who thought it
was all a kind of well managed system of
course the physicists say you know the
hell with this I mean they just want to
get their data samples and analyze them
and the source can be really from
anywhere so now we have moral mesh where
if you're right your tier 2 or tier 3
site you get your data from any one of a
number of places and data flows over
networks in much more complex ways so we
needed this aggregate use of all these
facilities to get all the data processed
and analyzed lately we realized that
we're going to and starting to run out
of computing resources so we also
sometimes send some of the data into the
cloud through overcome some of the peak
needs and there's this this concept of
any job anywhere of trying to put jobs
where there are computational resources
and storage space available so basically
now you've got this global dynamic
system and how data flows and how to get
the work done
namely how to optimize the workflow is a
big problem and so I'm deeply involved
in developing advanced networked systems
to help with this but in the end once we
create these mechanisms there will be
this problem of optimization where some
of the modern methods in deep learning
could be very applicable ok so I wanted
a finish to keep on the physics for a
while but I did want to mention so
you've got this picture of global
dataflow at an expanding rate it's
growing exponentially I'll come back to
that I mean for example right now we
have about half of an exabyte stored
among the sites and so it's challenging
the world's networks and so we're
developing systems which to handle this
and eventually as I said we want to use
deep learning one thing I haven't
touched upon and we're not into it yet
but I must say even if we manage to do
that the final step in this process is
to find stable solutions namely if I
have let's say about a 200 sites I can
derive what I think is optimal according
to a simple metric let the speed of
processing the data but there are other
factors like fair sharing and also
justifying the existence of certain
facilities so you can't starve any so
it's a problem which requires stable
solution
you know like Nash equilibrium or not
coming up with solutions which the next
day you have a revolution
okay so back to physics so let's go
through some of the things that led to
discovery about the Higgs boson so the
first thing is how our Higgs boson is
produced within the protons there are
constituents called gluons which bind
the quarks in the protons together and
it's those that are most frequently the
ones which interact so you can see the
highest curve is telling you the rate of
production of of Higgs particles for
Higgs well we happen now we plot them
for Higgs mass of 125 GeV because we
know that's what its mass is and so the
most frequent process is called gluon
fusion where two gluons come together
and then through this process which is
shown in the upper right involving what
we call a quark loop then you can get a
Higgs boson there are other processes so
what can happen is a fork and at that
quark for two quarks are going along
they each radiate a weak boson like a W
so I can get to W so get these and they
can fuse together on the on the Left to
form Higgs boson that's down by about an
order of magnitude although it's rarer
those things because there are also two
leftover forks which form two Jet's
that's more distinctive and so the
signal to background ratio can be larger
similarly if we create a Higgs as shown
in the green over there on the right
we'll have left over in this rare a
signature what's called an effective
bosanna wrz and if that decays into
involving electrons or muons that also
gives a better signature so we get a
rarer process but a largest signals of
background ratio and then finally in the
lower left you see what is called a tiki
bar Higgs well a Higgs particle
associated with a pair of top quarks
and the top pork decays also give you
some distinction that's much rarer it's
down by a good two orders of magnitude
from the most common production mode but
its distinctive and can also tell you
how heavy forks like top forks whether
they coupled to the Higgs in just the
way you expect the other thing that's
shown is as the energy of the Machine
went up from the first cycle of running
called Run 1 in 2009 to 2012 to run to
the energy went up and so the production
rates you see the numbers went up for
different processes by two to four times
what is this gate y-axis scale
so this is the cross-section for
producing the Higgs in Pico Barnes so if
you want to compare the rate one way to
think about it is the basic interaction
that say of proton-proton collisions at
these energies is about a hundred mill
abarnes okay or about these are Pico
Barnes so if I compare a hundred mill
abarnes it's ten to eleven times a Pico
born okay so so these are units of Pico
Barnes or ten to the minus twelve Barnes
the strong interaction when the first
people consider it they want to express
it as a cross-section equivalent to the
as an analogy the area of a disc so
imagine you're trying to colliding
things and you say well how often do
things collide well it depends upon the
size of this disc and the first thing
was called the barn like big like the
sight of a barn which is ten to the
minus twenty four centimeter square and
this is a peak of barn the units is ten
to the minus thirty six centimeter
square and the Higgs production rate at
at 13 T V where we're running now
it's about forty people you're actually
asking two questions at one the
production of Higgs in all s decay modes
is fairly large overall now about four
million Higgs bosons have been produced
however to find them the main way to
find them is through these distinctive
signatures for example there's one there
are two types of very important decays
which I'll get to in a moment let me get
to that
so once the Higgs is produced it again
decay in many ways and what you can see
on the left
is the the branching ratio of all the
decays what's the percentage that at the
k's in different ways the most probable
way because the higgs couples to mass it
likes to couple to the heaviest
available particle which is like a
bottom quark which is about six times
the mass of a proton so the largest
branching ratio is to a Higgs a bottom
quark and anti-bonding court but that
words results in a couple of jets and
it's nearly impossible not quite but
nearly impossible to pick out those
events so you have to focus first of all
on rare the case so what I've listed
here is with the Higgs being in the mass
range that it is it can decay
significantly in many ways to a pair of
Z bosons which turns out to be important
you'll see in a moment a pair of photons
W particles tau particles or or B Beadon
quarks the rare decays the Higgs stuff
to two photons which is about 0.2
percent and then the Higgs going to two
Z bosons but we don't measure the Z
bosons we see these very distinctive
signature where it goes into either a
plus c minus c plus c minus or plus e
minus mu plus or minus those are very
rare things only because on top of a big
production rate the each is e decay to a
pair of leptons is only 3% overall the
whole process is only point zero one
percent of all the Higgs particles but
it's one of those channels which
provides us the most information and the
other thing is that in these these
reactions where I have two photons or I
have for leptons I can measure all the
energy in the event and I can
reconstruct the invariant mass and
that's what gives us gives me the most
sensitive way to distinguish that
there's a particular mass at which these
things are being produced above the grow
up the background namely a resonance
that you can see compared to the
background the next important thing is
shown down there you can produce a pair
of W
articles it's good in that the W
particles in these relatively rare the
case can decay to leptons but the point
is you also have neutrinos so you don't
get a mass beat so we look at all these
things and test the couplings to all
these processes but in the discovery and
understanding what the higgs mass is
where it is it's really the two rare
signatures the Higgs to z z to four
leptons and takes the two photons that
have had a very special role and also
because the mass resolution you come out
with in the end picking out those final
States and reconstructing the mass is of
order one percent all right so here we
try to represent some of the signatures
in our detector if you look this is kind
of cartoons to illustrate what's going
on so Higgs to gamma gamma is on your
left what you see is when the two
photons come out there many other tracks
from other particles that were produced
but the two photons themselves don't
leave a track in the inner layers of the
detector and deposit their energy and
what's called the electrolytic
calorimeter in our experiment it was
those crystals and we get precise
measurements of their energy and
direction in the case of haste is easy
to in that one a plus a minus B plus
tree - you have the electron electron
which have two tracks and then the
energy is absorbed in the crystals again
and you get again pretty precise
measurements of the energies then you
have a pair of muons and for the muons
you don't see them go all the way but
they leave a track inside they go
through the crystals depositing a little
bit of energy they go into the other
layer so make sure they get to the
outside and you see these tracks outside
going a long way which are then bent in
the large the high magnetic field and
you get a good measure of their momentum
and then you see a Higgs in the third
panel headaches accompanied by a Z boson
the Higgs in that one decays the way it
really would like to most often to a
bottom quark and anti bottom quark the Z
then goes to four leptons e plus e minus
mu plus mu minus and it's those
occurrence of the leptons that allows
you to get some discriminating power and
then finally Higgs 2ww get leptons you
can get an electron each one is
different so an electron and positron
electron and muon you be plus nu minus
and then because there are neutrinos you
also see that in the transverse plane
there seems to be some missing energy
that the energy in the transverse plane
is not balanced this is just a blow-up
of one of the candidates now the first
thing to say say oh that's a beautiful
event
now the Higgs to gamma gamma event well
in spite of our best efforts the ratio
signal to background is still rather
small you'll see that so that's probably
a standard model partly a standard model
process that produces affair a pair of
photons it's rare but it happens and it
happens more often than you get the
Higgs going to the pair of photons so
the analysis at a high level look simple
look for two isolated high-energy
photons coming out and then we try to
optimize the analysis by optimizing the
methods by which we identify and measure
the energies of the photons look at the
properties of the entire event to try to
boost the probability that this is a
Higgs boson rather than a standard model
production of a pair of photons and then
also try to pick out events where the
photons are very well measured so you
give heavier weight to the ones in which
you think the energy is better measured
so you get better overall resolution
then you have specific categories in the
analysis for those other processes the
rarer processes where the Higgs is a
is associated with two additional jets
in the forward backward direction the
additional leptons if there was a Z or W
produced together with it and so on
that's the thesis the defense of one of
my students a few months after the
discovery okay so we worked on this
channel actually for 20 years from the
time of the superconducting
supercollider and so I had many students
over the years who contributed to this
analysis there was a great emphasis on
precise calibration for electrons and
photons optimizing the photon
identification methods how you set the
energy scale precisely so that each
event has the same scale so you can see
a bump by the particular mass for the
high-resolution within a sample of
events and innovative analysis methods
now for today we can highlight the fact
that among these many students we had
the first boost of decision tree
analysis so as time went on Hydra
physicists finally got involved in
neural networks first simple ones with
say a single hidden layer then this was
one of our students it's the one in the
lower left who's now at the center for
naval analyses some years ago he came up
with the first booster decision tree
analysis and since that time
Maurice berapa Lu who will talk here
soon and some of her students have also
developed special variables called the
Razr variables which have helped with
new particle searches one of the next
things that we're going to do in spite
of our best efforts and our previous
conviction that we had optimized things
is we're now starting to learn that in
many corners of our analysis that deep
learning approaches can make further
progress for us okay so when this is all
done this is again shortly after the
discovery you could see the little bump
that's actually quite a significant bump
and to illustrate it you can see what it
looks like unweighted and then if you
wait each one according to the ratio
signals the background that you've
computed in your analysis what it looks
like now actually there was a person
here Josh in the upper right-hand corner
who really has applied multivariate
methods and booster decision trees
there's actually here a flowchart of
multivariate analysis components of the
overall analysis to extract the signal
and so if you look carefully you take
the information from the detector the
clusters of energies and the crystals
and the other calorimeter layers the
reconstructed tracks the charge tracks
the momenta and direction the the energy
deposited in the electromagnetic and
hydronic calorimeter and then you look
at various aspects of the events you
look at the probability that the vertex
configuration if I look at the the
charge tracks and how the energy is
recoiling against the charge tracks for
example when I when I have two these two
photons what is the probability of
fitting the vertex how well is the
vertex resolved how well are the photons
reconstructed there's a regression to
optimize the single photon energy and
improve the resolution there's a cluster
regression to take the individual of
crystal energies and how you cluster
them to represent an electron or photon
in the crystals there's a vertex
probability another multivariate
analysis done to enhance the probability
that you're looking at a Higgs boson
production and then also there's a
photon ID part to boost the chance that
this is a real photon then you start to
put it together you were extracted by
photon mass you estimate what is the
estimated resolution from the
characteristics of the photons event by
event you get a resolution on the mass
you also get an overall vertex
probability namely what is the position
and the likelihood that it's a Higgs
boson of the primary vertex then finally
you extract a mass and properties of the
the Higgs like its direction other
kinematic quantities so the whole
flowchart of multivariate techniques
some are classifiers some are regression
to optimize values like the energy of
the photon you're looking at all right
then after doing all this you still
classify the output of an overall this
overall is treated as a booster this
entry and then you categorize things and
that boosts the that improves the
discriminating power further so you see
we have four categories you have one
where the signal to background ratio is
pretty high and the measurements are
very good category zero both aren't that
many events and then there are other
categories maybe the most powerful one
is like the first category and you can
see that how the signal tends to move to
the right relative to the backgrounds
the backgrounds can come just from the
Jets of particles very rare cases in
which you get a fake you think that the
jet jet includes two the Jets include
two photons and then also you get this
standard model production of photons
which you know as far as the final state
is concerned are not really
distinguishable except you can find the
mass peak from the signal that you
wouldn't see otherwise so as time went
on this little signal emerge and also I
think let's see was this an ear of
perhaps justices just after the time
before the discovery made this
transition we had the simple cut based
selection analysis and then after that
we came up with this booster decision
trees first simply and then a whole
flowchart of booster decision trees and
it really improved our ability to
extract the signal with
amount of data with a given significance
so when I show from the sort of early
days on the left is an era just before
announcement of the discovery we're in
this one Channel
there was a four standard deviation
emerging indication of a signal now we
look at so much data in so many
processes that our community has come up
with some standards or some de facto
standards we use to distinguish signals
from backgrounds so when you see a 3
Sigma effect it means a 3 standard
deviation effect
it's called evidence and if it's 5
tented deviations it's called the
discovery now that's a global what's
called a global 3 Sigma or 5 Sigma
namely you also have to take into
account how many bins you're actually
looking in so there's something called
the look elsewhere effect and so you
know seeing a fluctuation even what
looks like a 5 standard deviation
fluctuation in a given region and one
plot doesn't mean anything unless you
take into account that you could have
seen such a thing anywhere and you're
actually sampling many bins in this
example we run with a certain amount of
data which is in terms of luminosity is
about 5% what we have now first at a
central mass energy of 70 V now be run
at 13 then at 8 in 2012 and at the time
of the discovery that's what we had and
we had a 4 sigma effect in this channel
then we had also other channels had some
effect and taken together it reached 5
Sigma and so then CMS and Atlas on July
4th there was a seminar and they both
announced they had these effects and
then it was the discovery by the time we
finished a 2012 analysis this was the
middle of a run with about four times as
much data we had six standard deviations
in this channel and also in an in the
other channel which I'll say a bit about
about it about the use of these booster
decision trees the net effect we saw was
a boost in sensitivity by about a factor
of 1.8 and we would have had to run
about eighty percent longer for the
discovery otherwise which is you know
many years longer in the wrong in the
long run and for rare signatures it's
really crucial so this is what the bumps
looked like in CMS and out lists at the
end of the first run which ended at at
the late fall of 2012 they each had a
clean a signal shown here and they also
able to determine the mass rather well
and check that the production rate was
how it compared to the predictions of
the standard model and so this mule
represents the relative production
strength it says what is the production
rate that I observe compared to what the
standard model predicts and you can see
within these errors which are of one or
twenty percent and it agreed with the
standard model I just wanted to mention
at least one of the other channels this
is another type of event a beautiful
signature where Higgs goes to two Z
bosons the Higgs not is not heavy enough
to produce two real Z bosons one of them
is off shell namely it appears in the
diagram for the process but it it's not
it cannot be extracted you know as a
free particle it's called a virtual
particle and that's why it's listed as a
z-star but nevertheless the final state
is for leptons be plus or minus mu plus
nu minus e plus e minus e plus e minus
or a plus or minus mu plus or minus so
these are very distinctive signatures
and you can see a picture of of such an
event with the low rate which I already
mentioned
now when the experiments then looked
across the various production rates and
ways in which things decayed and took
all their signatures and tried to
separate out what is the strength for
each production mode remember this blue
on blue infusion
there's vector boson fusion there's
associated production associated with a
of a Higgs and a 0 W and Higgs together
with the top anti top pair one is the
rate of production compared to the
standard model you can see the error
bars are pretty big but overall it
really agreed with the standard model
and if you combine the results from
Atlas and CMS you've got agreement
within about ten percent so all
couplings are consistent with the
standard model with a precision which is
improving but still pretty big 20 to 60
percent observation of 5 Sigma this
standard value we use where the
probability of seeing a fluctuation or
background only is very low we see it
now on the gamma gamma Z Z and W W boson
channels recently in the last several
months in our experiment we've also made
an observation of the Higgs going to a
pair of the heavy leptons the tau
particles topless Tom - and both
experiments have looked at the details
I'll say a few words about that about
the final configuration of what's
produced in some of these channels which
are illuminating in terms of the
properties of the decay and also shows
that it almost certainly is a particle
of a 0iu momentum which is what is
predicted as the Higgs boson in the
standard model so within the standard
model I said that the Higgs boson
couples to mass so if you express it in
just the right way you can show whether
or not the coupling really does follow
the mass laws do you expect both for
spin 1/2 particles which are called the
fermions
for the bosons like the wnz which have
one unit of spin and you could see the
data points from Atlas and CMS on the
left of following the straight line
which is what the standard model
predicts
a couple slides ago I think was the
first time you had data in separate from
Atlas and CMS could you comment on the
arguments for the independence of those
two yes so these are each each detector
has certain strengths these designs are
actually quite different so my
experiment is called a compact muon
solenoid
what does compact mean well it is
smaller than Atlas but doesn't really
mean small it means dense and so we have
a 4 Tesla magnetic field which is very
difficult and for that reason our
detective is smaller and we have all
these crystals which have high
resolution Atlas also has a high
resolution electromagnetic calorimeter
but with a very different technology our
muon system you see is between the
layers of iron and sort of the topology
of the layout of the chambers is rather
regular in their case they got too much
bigger volumes and have these muon
stations in air so there are many
possible systemic effects and having two
is really a very very valuable cross
check you also mentioned that for
discovery on this level it was not done
with one experiment it's when the two
experiments had really both reached the
level of being able to announce the
discovery that discovery was sort of put
out there there are other examples which
are perhaps more instructive so before
in the same tunnel before the LHC was
the large electron positron Collider
there were four experiments and there we
got lessons that we had one experiment
that announced a few things that the
other experiments and so there are you
know given that you're so motivated to
find something you optimize your methods
and
can eventually convince yourself that
you have something and it's not part of
my talk but the structure is like this
so one way of doing analysis is you tune
your selection criteria until you say
I'm gonna have zero background and so if
I see one event then that's a real
signal in other words you can imagine
that you can calculate the probability
of a background of a background event
being 10 to the minus something you know
and so if I see one event they say hey
that's a signal but if you don't have a
way to really check that you don't and
in particular there might be rare
signatures in your background that you
don't understand so anyway we've had
counter examples that show the value in
that case of four experiments and we're
very convinced that two experiments with
very different designs are extremely
valuable especially when you have
something like this which essentially
can't changes the course of your
thinking this is like a branch in the
road you don't take the wrong branch and
so it's very valuable that we have these
two experiments it's also dynamic if one
experiment starts to come up with
something we haven't had this in a very
severe form we've had it in minor forms
and the other is very motivated to go
after this and check and they both work
together in check so it's a it's a it
really stabilizes the scientific process
alright I was here so what about the
couplings
so I'll clearly as mentioned the
standard model predicts couplings to the
different species and to which into
which it can decay and so the different
reactions give you different information
in terms of the couplings so to make a
simple picture we normalize all the
couplings in these parameters which are
called the Kappa which is a ratio of the
coupling strength to that predicted in
the standard model the Kappa v is the is
coupling to vector bosons like the W
the Kappa F is assuming it's the same to
all fermions such as the BB bar quarks
are fermions
or the leptons like Cal Plus tell - and
you see the different reactions give you
different contours but when you put it
all together the joint contour is really
clustering around one for each which
means compatible with the standard model
alright so that was run one and then in
the last couple of years starting in
2015 and continuing at the end of this
year we've been running at 13 T V now
what's interesting about the higher
energy is you can produce new things and
the advantage of producing new things
it's greater the greater the mass so you
have this dynamic situation you know
have protons inside the protons there
are Forks and gluons but they also have
motion inside the system so when I bring
them together
I can produce heavier things and the
higher the energy of the protons the
greater the chance of reducing
everything's so what you see for
starting at the top with the most common
interactions 13 TV or a TV is only an
advantage increase rate by one point -
as I start to go down the rate of
producing individual vector bosons w's
and Z's - Z's it gets up to about a
advantage of - for the Higgs it's an
advantage of 2 to 2.5 for heavier
species like the top quark it's 3 to 4
and then if there are new things suppose
we have objects which we don't know yet
which are several TeV remember in these
units the Higgs is 125 GV or an eighth
of a TV that the advantage is enormous
for the heaviest particles and so energy
is really at a premium and so 13 T V is
a new a new opportunity to see new
things well first of all immediately we
reproduce the Higgs analysis again we
got extremely good measurements the mass
is now determined it was already
determined to 0.2% now individual
experiments or 0.2 percent or better
amazing for a particle that was
discovered so we recently how well we
know it's mass and in this process easy
to for leptons you can also see other
things so for example there's the Higgs
which is sticking out as a signal over
the backgrounds which is shown in this
sort of pink or red color and then the
backgrounds and there's a rare process
on the left that's kind of an internal
standard that shows us we are really
reconstructing things well because
there's a standard model process for
producing for leptons which is not the
Higgs on the left and so the background
as well is well predicted and also the
kinematics if you remember you have one
z0 which is a real z0 and so it has a
certain mass which is like 91 GV on the
same scale where the Higgs is 125 but
the other one is virtual and so there
should be a relationship team the mass
of one left on pair versus the other and
you can see it over there and if you
look at the the points compared to the
predictions which is represented sort of
vaguely as this grey background which
gets more dense near that position for
the mass of one of these zeros that it
really does follow then we did a lot
more we wanted to know whether this is a
spin zero or something else and so you
write down the most general theory this
is an expression in the upper right for
a general expression for a spin to
particle and on the left to spin one
particle and now if I look at the Higgs
to Z Z 2 for leptons I have a lot of
information so you can define the two
the lepton pairs can tell you there are
two planes which are defined by those
two pairs of vectors and you can look at
the production and decay angles of these
things and ask you ask yourself what is
most likely and so for a whole range of
models there's one exotic model for each
of these vertical bands you look at the
likelihood ratio between whether the
data that we have is more likely from a
spin 0 particle is 0 with positive
parity it's a 0 plus or something else
and so you see the likelihood JP so it's
a log likelihood that were ratio that
we're looking at and you can see that
the data when tested against what we
have we test against the data it always
favors the orange or red bands over the
blue ones which are the alternative so
no matter what we tested against there's
a preference that this is the spin 0
particle like the standard model since
well so this is run to 1 and maybe a
little bit the beginning of run to this
is what it was like you know this is not
far from Geneva but point here is that
we had this mountain in front of us
which is you know there's a standard
model working and can we complete it or
not and now we've completed it but now a
bit we don't know where we are so I gave
a talk like this little different at a
conference in in Manaus in the Amazon
this is the Amazon River so now we're on
a river of discovery what does it mean
these we don't really know where we are
we didn't find supersymmetry
we're looking for whether it still may
be true or what other exotic physics
there is we know the standard model is
not all there is the simplest argument
for what lies beyond the standard model
are here first of all we know that Dark
Matter exists in fact it makes up most
of the matter in the universe and you
can see that in the Galactic rotation
curves the fact that there is excess VAS
that sort of binds the galaxies were
just spinning in a certain rate together
you can also see that in galaxy clusters
and superclusters you can see it in
distortions in the light that comes to
you when there's mass between you and
the source of the light so called
gravitational lensing which sometimes
produces multiple images and sometimes
even like here seems to smear out some
of the Astrophysical objects remote
galaxies in ways that we explained by
Dark Matter in the middle and we also
know that dark energy dark matter and
dark energy have key roles that the
whole shape of the universe as it
appears for example the ratio of
clusters of matter and voids between
them and the largest scales would be
different if we didn't have just about
the amount of dark energy that we that
we have namely about 70% of all the
energy in the universe is dark energy
anyway so dark matter is missing from
the standard model and the other thing
I've told you that's wrong is this the
Higgs mass is 125 GeV if you try to
project back using the quantum field
theories that we know back to the early
universe which is equivalent to
projecting it to very high energy scales
you find out that the university is that
the universe is not stable is it
unstable not really in the sense that
the time in which it would transition
from the vacuum we live in to something
else where we wouldn't be here is much
longer than the age of the universe so
there's a plot the Green is stable the
red is unstable and the yellow is
metastable and the data seems to
increase to indicate that were there in
the metastable reason region it also
lines which are fascinating those
numbers 10 to the 11 10 to the 12 10 to
the 13 that's where the Higgs self
coupling becomes negative which
alternately alternatively interpreted
that's where if there's an intermediate
mass range something else happening
it may exist and that seems to be in the
range of 10 to the 10 to the 10 to 10 to
the 12 GB and remember we're running in
our experiments at 13 GB or 13,000 geez
perhaps this would be a good time to get
some questions so then you have these
multiple layers of what do you exactly
sense in those materials is it the
temperature is it so definitely is a
difference so for example the trackers
tend to be silicon detectors when a
charged particle goes through a silicon
detector for every 30 electron volts
that's deposited you get an electron
hole pair so essentially you're looking
mainly at the electrons which give you
an electronic signal in the case of the
crystals
they're called scintillators so when a
charged particle goes through them or
photon goes into them but then almost
immediately converts into
electron-positron pair then the result
is light the light in that case goes
through the crystals and reaches a photo
sensor where the light is then converted
to electronic signal which is then read
out and as somewhat similarly in the
Hadron calorimeter there are layers of
plastic which are scintillator so most
of the energy goes into the heavy
material which in that case is brass but
in the plastic again you get light and
then there are photo sensors which
convert it to electronic signals which
are right now
yeah in the case of the muon chambers in
the forward direction it's again solid
state like silicon sensors in the end
but in the central region it's gas
detectors and silicon tracker the
typical resolutions are of order 20
microns in the case of the crystals the
measurements are sort of in the range of
1% for an energy for high-energy
electrons and photons is what matters in
the case of the muon chambers we depend
upon this bending over a large bending
radius and it reaches it's designed so
that even for a very high momentum of
muons because they can be very important
as coming from new particles new heavy
particles that up to about 1 kV we still
have a resolution of 10% and it's sort
of proportional to the momentum so ok
in terms of Jets of particles for very
high energy Jets it gets down to like
several to ten percent but for a lot of
the others we have resolutions of the
order of 20 and in lower case even 30%
like 5%
I mean in a single cell well
yeah let me take the example of a photon
in the bunch of crystals the crystal
sizes are chosen so that a small set of
crystals transversely will contain the
energy so they're long enough so that
it's contained longitudinally
and they are large enough well they're
small enough so you can get a very good
measure of what the angle is but also
large enough that just a few contain the
whole thing so a typical set of crystals
for a high-energy electron photon might
be somewhere between nine and twenty
five and if the particle goes into one
crystal right in the middle seventy-six
percent of the total energy is just that
one crystal but then it varies if it
goes if it in a different position it
gets shared so we don't care so much
about you know what is measured in the
crystal but in this so-called physics
object this cluster of crystals we care
and similarly you know we don't really
care I mean the signal to background
ratio in the silicon tracker is like 14
to one but we care too to pick out from
the pulse the position then we have a
bunch of positions make our trajectory
in space the bending and knowing the
magnetic field gives you in momentum we
care about the momentum and the angle so
we can measure the topology of the event
through the angles at the production
point and also the momentum and so we
get a kinematic picture and a geometric
picture of what the event looks like
that answer your question so you're
trying to identify these signatures of
the different ways of things can decay
how accurately do you think you're
identifying that you could see you get a
hint for example in that strength plot
my channel you can see that as the so
overall for the entire set of decays we
say that the strength you know is
getting measured that to about the 10%
level and if you look down at the size
of the error bars you see they're
getting bigger so we have a real ways to
go in terms of you know when we pin down
for every channel precisely what it's
coupling is we have quite a ways to go
my question is more you're like seeing
this data you're trying to classify what
neat events happen but there's these
other things that are making the day
they're noisy how do you know how act
like how often you're seeing something
worse missing it from the noise well I
mean essentially for each so for each
channel you have sort of likelihood of
signal versus background you have two
main levers to check what you're doing
one is when you're identifying particles
that go into the decision you have
certain processes that you know what
they are and you can reconstruct the
mess and say you know I understand those
properties in terms of signal versus
background you look at likelihood ratios
of signal plus background versus
background and you also extract the
significance the significance is
expressed in terms of what is the
likelihood that if I have no signal I
have a fluctuation which produced this
apparent signal and so we use that and
so there's been an entire development of
the concepts of how you use the log
likelihood ratios and also give a
penalty when things don't fit exactly so
that you have
you have a measure which has what's
called the right coverage namely that
you really have a good measure of the
significance you don't underestimate too
much or overrate overestimate the
significance so to see the ways that I
can point you to a paper that will tell
you you know exactly what are the
statistical methods and one of the
properties of these log likelihood
ratios and all the rest you know how do
we know we have 3 Sigma 4 Sigma 5 Sigma
equivalent and then also as I mentioned
also look elsewhere effect so there's
been long discussion makes sure that
we're not making any mistakes in terms
of significance suppressing fake signals
understanding you know when you have a
low enough probability of a fluctuation
from background and so on so that's my
short explanation of a set of paper you
mentioned that your computational
methods have evolved very much we had a
we had a conversation between us along
these lines I probably looks like I
probably won't get to this today but so
what happens is you you derive these
methods for identifying certain types of
things like a B quark really you see a
jet from a B quark and people now you
know for a long time thought they were
doing as well as they could possibly do
and then when I started to apply deep
learning message so these are doing
better maybe at some stage before I
stopped we should have a break but
before I stop I should jump to that and
show you some of that it's like a whole
community within a discipline scientific
discipline has a certain maturity has
reached a point where they believe
they're doing the best I can
then new methods come along and
- emitter and even the abstractions are
abstractions we never thought would
happen I have an example which is taken
from student working in our group
working with Maria and abstract
representations once you've identified
particles by our standard method you
want to go from that to what is the
origin of this entire event and so you
you just put geometric shape on the
plane that represents these particles in
the places where they are you know in
terms of the angles the two angles one
is proportional to polar angle from the
beam and the other there's some useful
angle so you unroll that and you put
these images there and it seems to be
doing better in distinguishing these
types of events than anything that came
before even though we don't understand
the abstraction
now their particular papers you could
point us to yes so what I have in my
slides there is this nips conference and
so there were three papers there I
wanted to highlight two which are
accepted as posters and one of them has
has to do with these abstract images and
so identify another example I have is
the Atlas Callaghan so so I came in
touch with that I I was at the
supercomputing conference where I run
these large-scale exercises and networks
and we hosted a number of other teams
and one of them was the Atlas team which
took this generative adversarial
networked generation of shower profiles
at high speed and they did a
demonstration there and so I have in my
slide some of that but then I also
noticed you're on your website right
there's this note about about Gans
in other words you know it's recognizing
something what is recognizing we don't
really know
we've been working you very hard and
working the audience for the art maybe
we should take a little yeah I'll I'll
jump to some of the recent work of deep
learning method